studio head Samuel Goldwyn once told
six-time Oscar winner Billy Wilder you
have all the scenes now just go home and
wordid him that's one of the biggest
problems writers face people think what
they do is easy the better the writer
the easier it looks these women and men
a master storytellers they work so hard
to make it look so easy here are the
nominees for Best Original Screenplay
the big sink written by Emily V Gordon
get out written by Jordan pier
Lady Bird written by Greta Gauri
the shape of water screenplay by
guillermo del toro mr. Taylor story by
guillermo del toro three billboards
outside every Missouri written by Martin
McDonagh
and the Oscar goes to Jordan Peele
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
thank you you guys are gonna you guys
are gonna mess up my jetski hold up this
means so much to me I stopped writing
this movie about 20 times because I
thought it was impossible I thought it
wasn't gonna work I thought no one would
ever make this movie but I kept coming
back to it because I knew if someone let
me make this movie that people would
hear it and people would see it so I
want to dedicate this to all the people
who raise my voice and let me make this
movie Donna
Ron at Universal everybody QC Shawn
Ted Bayer Jason at Blum House you guys
thank you so much to the cast and crew I
love you thank you so much my wife who
supported me through this whole process
my mother who taught me to love even in
the face of hate and to everybody who
went and saw this movie everybody who
bought a ticket who told somebody to buy
a ticket thank you I love you for
shouting out at the theater for shouting
out at the screen let's keep going Brian
Roberts thank you I love you all thank
you so much good night
[Applause]